this show came to be
because uh
jacqueline and i used to
i told you it's really hard for me to go
out yeah so i would call her because i
didn't get a chance to see my kid this
is my baby girl and i i'd call her and
we would laugh and do like uh prank
calls
for nothing yeah you know and my wife
came in one day and said why don't you
do a podcast so that's what this podcast
is but we wanted to keep
uh
true to whatever the seat of the idea so
i said if i have friends in and people
come in
do you want to partake in prank do you
like pranking
i mean you know i was just it's so funny
you said that i was with my son and i go
joe i hate being in a prank like i
i swear
today just today on the way on the way
we're at funko today which do you have a
funko
you need a funko
um i don't know i don't know if you're
saying something that's positive
your son knows what i'm talking about i
need a funko
yeah you need to get and i'm gonna oh
are those little square kind of the
square head it looks like a roblox uh uh
avatar but it's in in 3d yes i saw that
you have one yeah i have a bobble head
no we got to get you funko pop it's a
completely different culture it's it's
this it's this thing
and uh and yours would yours would crush
right there i have the deal or no deal
bobblehead yeah but
not a lot of people buying that right
now yeah no deal
i'm going to talk to the guy
to get me a funko of course why can't i
just have yours and tell people it's
mine
your funko put up put up a picture of uh
joe coy's funko because i saw it on and
i thought i'm just gonna carry this
around
i can make a box
yeah you should
i would love that you would love what if
you did that if you walked around
that's so cool
now here's the th
that's a real culture man they go crazy
for it i'm not joking so that could have
been me pre glasses
that's you right there it is that's
funko pop yep comedian joe coy look at
the different things they go for like 59
[Music]
47 what's the difference between a forty
five dollar one and a hundred dollars
hundred dollars these are just people
these are resales
they're reselling these things for a
hundred dollars over a hundred dollars
i'm kind of a big thing man
do you know who you're talking to dad oh
my god get me a funko
i i've been telling you that
wow they would go crazy i wanna i wanna
i wanna go funk myself
so if you get if you hear if anybody had
you have a connection with these people
yeah the with the uh the owner and the
uh and the guy that started i could tell
you a story i went to the i went to
funko and i said i was literally just
there and i i can't wait to take your
daughter there
they'll literally give you baskets and
she could just throw whatever she wants
in the basket that's as many punks yeah
i went to funko and i said i'd like to
do a funko and they said they're really
not interested there's not a market for
my funko and i said i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm going to make my own funko
all right well anyway so well that's
amazing so you were saying you were at
funko telling your son
we were there today that's why i was
late we were doing the funko thing uh
redoing i'm getting another funko bait
and um wait you do you actually uh
you model for it no no i was there
nowhere
i mean it's nice that you have a funko
but it doesn't really look like you
stand still and they no we're
redesigning a new one yeah
so i i'm getting i'm releasing another
one it i'm telling you
when you look at it you're like okay
what is that joe but it's it's huge it's
huge it's like basic it's the new
baseball cards
it's everyone collects those they go
crazy for it the minute it gets released
they just they gobble it up wow
and when you sign it forget about it
forget about it i know because it's not
a funko but i i think there is a funko
of gizmo from gremlins oh yeah yeah so
i'm always signing those at the back of
shows so that people had those and i
signed those but i don't make anything
but that's not me it's it i played the
character i did the voice but i'm done
talking to you i i got to tell you more
stuff
we you and i need to talk every time i
tell you so every time i come here i
tell you stuff
isn't that the point yeah but you don't
do it i don't do anything i'm a recluse
why because i'm [ __ ] up in the head
i am i'll be honest with you i don't
know if you saw the cover of people a
few weeks ago but i was the
people magazine said i'm the mentalist
man alive
they did not no but we me and uh my
daughter here we're on the cover
really yeah yeah yeah where is it can i
get a copy still or what is there one
somebody just sign i'll sign one for you
hold them up look at this i love it
you got funko we got mental health
coverage yeah you've got funko you got
funko we got [ __ ] up yeah
[Music]
bye